In diesem Kapitel werden wir erkunden,
wie Quanten- und klassische Computer
zusammenarbeiten, um eine der wichtigsten Herausforderungen
der Wissenschaft zu lösen: die genaue Schätzung der Energie von Molekülen
und Materialien. Das erreichen wir,
indem wir einen Quanten-circuit verwenden,
um Basis-Samples zu erzeugen,
die wir anschließend nachverarbeiten
und durch eine Reihe von Algorithmen diagonalisieren.
In dieser Familie von Verfahren
wie SQV und SKG gibt es einen ganzen Kurs auf
der IBM Quantum Plattform, der eigens
diesen und verwandten Methoden gewidmet ist.
Für unsere Zwecke in dieser Lektion werden wir
die Erklärung kurzhalten.
Egal ob du SQV oder SKG verwendest,
ist dein Ziel, Eigenvektoren
und Eigenwerte für eine Hamilton-Matrix zu finden.
Diese Matrix kann die Energie eines physikalischen
oder chemischen Systems beschreiben, aber dasselbe Framework
kann viele andere Problemtypen lösen,
wie zum Beispiel Logistik. Manchmal
sind diese Matrizen riesig.
Daher kann es sehr wertvoll sein,
die Dimensionen der Matrix zu reduzieren
und dabei wichtige Eigenschaften des Grundzustands
zu erhalten – das ist das Ziel von SQV.
Wir nutzen den Quantencomputer, um einen nützlichen Unterraum zu erzeugen,
der den Grundzustand enthält.
Wir können dann unsere Hamilton-Matrix
auf diesen Unterraum projizieren, was uns
eine kleine Matrix hinterlässt, die
viel einfacher zu diagonalisieren ist –
mit klassischem High-Performance-Computing. Dazu
bereiten wir einen Versuchs-Quantenzustand vor,
oft Ansatz genannt,
und führen Messungen durch, um diesen Ansatz zu sampeln.
In der Rechenbasis ergibt uns das
einen gesampelten Unterraum in der Rechenbasis.
Was wir aber wirklich finden wollen,
ist der wahre Grundzustand. Was,
wenn unser gesampelter Unterraum nicht
alle notwendigen Komponenten enthält?
Wenn wir einen besseren Ansatz wählen,
erhalten wir möglicherweise eine bessere Schätzung des Grundzustands.
Das führt uns zum sample-basierten
Krylov-Unterraum-Verfahren für die Quantendiagonalisierung, oder SKQD. Bei SKQD
beginnen wir mit einem Ansatz
wie zuvor, wenden dann aber Quanten-gates an, die
die Zeitentwicklung eines physikalischen Systems approximieren.
Es lässt sich zeigen, dass unter wenigen Annahmen
dies Garantien für die Überlappung zwischen der zeitentwickelten
Wellenfunktion und dem wahren Grundzustand liefert.
Beide Algorithmen starten mit einer riesigen
Hamilton-Matrix und arbeiten etwas unterschiedlich,
aber in beiden Fällen liefert der Quantenteil des Algorithmus
einen Unterraum, der es uns ermöglicht, unsere Matrix zu verkleinern
und dabei die wesentlichen Eigenschaften des Grundzustands zu erhalten.
Wo kommt also das klassische High-Performance-Computing ins Spiel?
Bei den größten Hamilton-Matrizen
und für die genauesten Schätzungen des Grundzustands
können selbst diese projizierten Matrizen recht groß sein.
Leistungsfähigere klassische Rechenkapazitäten zu nutzen
hilft uns dabei, nicht nur
bessere Ergebnisse zu erzielen,
sondern auch größere Probleme anzugehen.
Um alles zusammenzuführen:
Wir können sample-basierte Algorithmen
als eine Kombination verschiedener Programmiermodelle
auf einer Menge heterogener Ressourcen darstellen.
Zum Beispiel können wir unseren Algorithmus
als einen Task-Workflow darstellen, bei dem wir einen Task
für die Vorbereitung des Quanten-circuits haben, der
mit unserem Zielzustand überlappt, gefolgt von einem Task
für den transpiler, der nur klassische Ressourcen benötigt.
Als nächstes folgt der Task,
der Primitives verwendet, um unseren Quanten-circuit auszuführen,
was natürlich
Quantenressourcen erfordert. Danach folgt ein Nachverarbeitungs-Task, der selbst
ein paralleler Diagonalisierungsalgorithmus sein kann,
der auf mehreren Knoten läuft.
Außerdem möchten wir vielleicht
einen dieser Algorithmen viele Male ausführen,
während wir unseren Ansatz variieren,
oder sie vollständig parallel laufen lassen
mit verschiedenen Parametern.
Jetzt lass uns alles mit SKQD zusammenbringen
im Code. Hier sind alle unsere Task-Dateien
und hier alle unsere Submission-Dateien.
Im Mapping-Task bereiten wir circuits vor.
Im Optimierungsschritt führen wir die circuits auf die beste Art aus.
Im Ausführungs-Task sampeln wir Bitstings
aus dem Zustand, der von
unserem ISA-circuit vorbereitet wurde.
Den wir aus dem vorherigen Schritt erhalten
und führen unsere Nachverarbeitung durch.
Jetzt sind wir bereit, unseren
SKQD-Workflow einzureichen.
Wie du siehst, wird alles sequenziell ausgeführt
mit Abhängigkeiten. Lass uns warten,
bis die Ergebnisse vorliegen, und dann unsere Ausgabedateien prüfen.
Hier ist die Ausgabedatei des Optimierungsschritts,
in der wir unseren ISA-circuit haben.
Und lass uns abschließend unsere End-to-End-
Ausführung prüfen.
Aus dem Schedule.
Damit endet die kurze Demonstration des SKQD-Workflows.
Der gesamte Code wird im Textbereich
oder in der Beschreibung unten verfügbar sein.
Damit haben wir einige
Konzepte und Beispiele durchgegangen, die dir den Einstieg in
die Verwaltung komplexer hybrider Programme erleichtern. Natürlich
kratzt das nur an der Oberfläche von
allem, was du mit der Kombination aus Quanten-
und klassischen Ressourcen machen kannst. Um mehr zu entdecken,
schau dir die Dokumentation und Tutorials an
auf der IBM Quantum Plattform.
Sieh dir auch die Ressourcen an, die im Textbereich
oder in der Beschreibung geteilt werden, für weitere Tools
und Software. Danke fürs Zuschauen.
Ja, das war's.